Jake:呀呀
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 好玩吗
Lucia: Is it fun?
Jake:好玩也很重要
Jake: Yeah, it's fun and important.
Jake:这个很重要要齐了
Jake: This is important, it needs to be even.
Jake:这个边上我要挤很多
Jake: I need to squeeze a lot around the edges.
Tasha: 是吧其实我觉得
Tasha: Right, actually I think...
Tasha: 如果你能把周围一圈再挤下来
Tasha: If you could squeeze it all around...
Tasha: 然后再挤下来
Tasha: And then squeeze it down.
Tasha: 就像蛋糕周围
Tasha: Just like around a cake.
Jake:就是我要把这个都给填上
Jake: So, I need to fill all of this up.
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Tasha: 哎你看你应该把它转一圈来的
Tasha: Hey, look, you should turn it around once.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 转他一圈转他一圈
Tasha: Turn it around, turn it around.
Jake:这样子他就不会往上跑了哦
Jake: This way it won't move up.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:来了
Jake: Here it comes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈都在吃
Jake: Hahaha, everyone's eating.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈等饿了谁敢吃啊
Lucia: Haha, who dares to eat when they're hungry?
Tasha: 不是谁敢吃啊
Tasha: It's not about daring to eat.
Jake:哈哈哈不要靠你了
Jake: Hahaha, don't rely on you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:来吧哈哈哈哈
Jake: Come on, hahaha.
Lucia: 来吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Come on, haha.
Lucia: 西亚真傻
Lucia: Sia is so silly.
Tasha: 救命啊
Tasha: Help!
Lucia: 我来我你来你来你来
Lucia: I'll do it, you do it, you do it.
Jake:我来哈哈
Jake: I'll do it, haha.
Jake:你来你来
Jake: You do it, you do it.
Jake:你来我来我来
Jake: You do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Lucia: 等一下我先给你稍微整理一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second, let me tidy this up a bit first.
Jake:好玩吗好玩好
Jake: Is it fun? Yeah, it's fun.
Lucia: 不过
Lucia: But...
Lucia: 我觉得我可能跟你没法整理的很平坦
Lucia: I don't think I can make it very smooth with you.
Jake:玩
Lucia: 剩下的就要靠您自己了
Jake:哈哈哈
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: 就是挤完之后给他上面这弄平了
Lucia: 这一会要弄不平
Lucia: 您呢自己弄弄哈
Jake:我试试我试一下我看有多深哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 咱这好奇心用在合适的地方吧
Jake:哈哈哈
Lucia: 他想看看上面这层有多深
Jake:好好
Jake:好的好的好的好好
Jake:我来了来了
Tasha: 我已经迫不及待了
Lucia: 哈哈还是得有经验的
Lucia: Haha, experience really counts.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 票子是不是就像一个蛋糕了哈哈
Tasha: Does the ticket look like a cake now? Haha.
Lucia: 这让我想到那个
Lucia: This reminds me of that...
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: you know, in Harry Potter...
Lucia: 海格给哈利做那个蛋糕
Lucia: when Hagrid made that cake for Harry.
小薇 ：哦前段时间回来好利来卖那个
Tasha: Oh, recently, Holiland started selling those.
Lucia: 对对对是的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 就是第一次做蛋糕的人
Lucia: It's like the first cake someone makes.
Lucia: 做出来的蛋糕差不多就长那样
Lucia: It looks pretty much like that.
Lucia: 我现在相信了
Lucia: Now I believe it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: i'm totally convinced now
Lucia: I'm totally convinced now.
Jake:差不多啊
Jake: Almost there.
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: It looks pretty good.
Tasha: 整挺好整挺好
Tasha: It looks pretty good, really good.
Jake:整挺好我再整整
Jake: It looks good, I'll keep at it.
Jake:我真想知道他有多高
Jake: I really want to know how tall he is.
Lucia: 不是吧
Lucia: No way.
Jake:我刚刚好歹要这个东西我没整
Jake: I just needed this thing, but I didn't get it.
Lucia: 啊那你们现在几点
Lucia: Oh, what time is it for you guys now?
Jake:色泽水深
Jake: The color is deep.
Lucia: 测点水深
Lucia: Measure the water depth.
Lucia: 水深2.二点几
Lucia: The water depth is 2 point something.
Lucia: 马克图的那个2.5英尺
Lucia: Mark it as 2.5 feet.
Lucia: 我们已经毫来毫不在意
Lucia: We totally don't care anymore.
Jake:哈哈哈很好吃
Jake: Hahaha, it's delicious.
Lucia: 哈哈哈很好吃吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it really delicious?
Jake:吗啊吃一个
Jake: Yeah, try one.
Lucia: 啊吃一个
Lucia: Ah, try one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: It's okay, just look at you.
Lucia: 先看这水深
Lucia: First, check the water depth.
Lucia: 没有2.5英尺
Lucia: It's not 2.5 feet.
Lucia: 哇有点像蛋糕啊
Lucia: Wow, it looks a bit like a cake.
Lucia: 说实话不像汉堡
Lucia: Honestly, it doesn't look like a burger.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:谢谢鼓励
Jake: Thanks for the encouragement.
Lucia: 杨老师这技术可以嗯
Lucia: Jake, your skills are good, hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈不是这个有点丑吧
Lucia: Haha, but isn't this a bit ugly?
Alice:好香啊好熏啊
Alice: It smells so good, so smoky.
Lucia: 叫什么叫碗大厦于江青哈哈哈
Lucia: What's it called, like a big dish building? Hahaha.
Jake:挽回作为蛋糕的尊严
Jake: Restore the dignity of the cake.
Jake:主要问题是不是我多多的要存了
Jake: The main problem is, isn't it that I need to save more?
Jake:我觉得也是
Jake: I think so too.
Jake:嗯就不太够
Jake: Yeah, it's not enough.
Jake:建材不够
Jake: Not enough materials.
Jake:就外边的漆就不刷了吧就是
Jake: So we won't paint the outside anymore, just...
Shure: 这不等你回去吃去吗
Shure: Aren't you waiting to eat it when you get back?
Jake:好怎么拯救
Jake: Okay, how to save it?
Lucia: 你刮好了吗
Lucia: Have you finished scraping it?
Jake:我可以没有刮好对吗
Jake: I may not have finished scraping it, right?
Lucia: 好那就已经刮好
Lucia: Okay, then it's already scraped.
Lucia: 然后开始在外形上拯救
Lucia: Then let's start saving the appearance.
Jake:怎么拯救
Jake: How to save it?
Lucia: 首先搞颜色
Lucia: First, work on the color.
Lucia: 然后搞蛋糕哦
Lucia: Then work on the cake, oh.
Lucia: 我再出去喝两口壮壮胆
Lucia: I'll go out and have a couple more drinks to boost my courage.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 这些杯子是随便哪一个用都行的
Lucia: Any of these cups are fine to use.
Jake:还行啊
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:还行我也觉得还行
Jake: It's okay, I think it's okay too.
Jake:好玩吗好玩
Jake: Is it fun? It's fun.
Lucia: 哪一个呀
Lucia: Which one?
Tasha: 哈哈做蛋糕其实还挺好玩的吧
Tasha: Haha, making cakes is actually pretty fun, right?
Jake:确实确实好玩
Jake: It really is, it's fun.
Lucia: 喝上口再进去弄那个蛋糕
Lucia: Take a sip and then go make that cake.
Jake:嗯好玩
Jake: Yeah, it's fun.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Jake:往往往里边哎
Jake: Go, go, go inside, hey.
Tasha: 哎那天你不是玩过吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you play that the other day?
Jake:对啊好
Jake: Yeah, it's good.
Jake:要玩好要玩
Jake: You gotta play well, gotta play.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:是像吗哈哈
Jake: Does it look like it? Haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Jake:就照着那个做的就好了吗好了
Jake: Just follow that and it'll be good. Done.
Lucia: 巧克力粉吗
Lucia: Is this chocolate powder?
Jake:画龙点睛画蛇点睛
Jake: It's like the finishing touch.
Lucia: 到底想说什么
Lucia: What exactly are you trying to say?
Jake:就就牛逼牛逼好哈
Jake: Just, just, awesome, awesome, okay, ha.
Lucia: 哈哈这这这俩
Lucia: Haha, these two words have completely different meanings.
Lucia: 这俩词完全是不同的意思啊
Lucia: These two words have completely different meanings.
Shure: 油还不够是吗
Shure: Not enough oil, right?
Lucia: 你可考虑好
Lucia: You better think it through.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 神来之笔
Lucia: A stroke of genius.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 拍照拍照
Lucia: Take a picture, take a picture.
Shure: 杨老板回个头
Shure: Jake, turn around.
Alice:我想直接爆炒了
Alice: I just want to stir-fry it directly.
Alice:家人说实话
Alice: Honestly, family.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 很棒
Shure: Great.
Shure: 这是我的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates.
Shure: 这是我的被美女包围的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates surrounded by beauties.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好我来拯救他
Jake: Okay, I'll save him.
Jake:我也觉得行
Jake: I think it's fine too.
Katrina: 我在做蛋糕呢
Katrina: I'm making a cake.
Katrina: 我晚点跟你说
Katrina: 你先发给我吧 嗯 好
Katrina: 拜拜
Jake:这么忙
Katrina: 对，有点情况  他们明天答辩
Jake:噢
Tasha: 好啦
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da!
Katrina: 给个特写
Katrina: Give it a close-up.
Tasha: 杨老师做的真好看
Shure: 好大
Shure: It's huge.
Shure: 给你看看作者
Shure: Let me show you the creator.
Tasha: 你可以用这个切
Tasha: You can use this to cut it.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Here, Jake.
Shure: 切切切这历史性的一刀吧
Shure: Make the historic cut.
Jake:怎么切切
Jake: How should I cut it?
Tasha: 随便你啊
Tasha: However you like.
Tasha: 你想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it any way you want.
Shure: 你看5个就不好切
Shure: See, five pieces are hard to cut.
Shure: 这这时候就就可以问AI一个问题
Shure: This is the time to ask AI a question.
Shure: 我们放几个他更好切一些
Shure: How many pieces should we cut for easier slicing?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 好吵啊好吵
Shure: It's so noisy, so noisy.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈怎么能嫌弃我呢
Shure: Haha, how can you dislike me?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哎后面这个小心
Lucia: Hey, be careful at the back.
Shure: 你一天说的话够我一个星期说的话了
Shure: You say more in a day than I do in a week.
Shure: 留点面子留点面子
Shure: Give me a break, give me a break.
Shure: 免提呢免提呢
Shure: Speakerphone, speakerphone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 来来来杨老板吃串
Shure: Come on, Jake, have a skewer.
Jake:好没手了
Jake: Okay, my hands are full.
Jake:没关系好谢谢你
Jake: It's alright, thank you.
Jake:不敢下手
Jake: I'm afraid to start.
Shure: 历史性的一刀
Shure: The historic cut.
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 好像没给这盘子剁碎了然后把
Shure: Just make sure you don't break the plate.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈快刀斩乱麻
Lucia: Haha, cut the Gordian knot.
Shure: 哎呀我天呐
Shure: Oh my god
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright
Lucia: 哈哈哈卧槽爆浆了
Lucia: Hahaha, oh my, it's exploding
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh crap
Alice:what do you see
Alice: What do you see?
Katrina: 高楼大厦崩塌了
Katrina: The skyscrapers are collapsing
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful
Katrina: 紧急维修
Katrina: Emergency repair
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈紧急维修
Katrina: Hahaha, emergency repair
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 紧急公关
Katrina: Emergency PR
Jake:大楼要导致去拿胶带糊
Jake: The building's gonna need some tape to patch it up
Jake:我要不先切吧
Jake: How about I cut it first?
Lucia: 也行切了再放草莓吧
Lucia: That works, cut it and then add the strawberries
Jake:对我这个也抵一下
Jake: Yeah, I'll balance it too
Tasha: 他已经完全失去人们的样子了
Tasha: He doesn't look human anymore
Jake:有好的有好的
Jake: There are good parts, there are good parts
Jake:虽然不多
Jake: Though not many
Lucia: 最后一块是好的
Lucia: The last piece is good
Jake:你现在这个样子像不像那什么
Jake: Don't you look like... something
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 路路华福
Lucia: Luluwah
Shure: 有你那个绝对就已经不是人类范畴
Shure: With yours, it's definitely beyond human
Lucia: 可丽饼
Lucia: Crepe
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Can we do it?
Shure: 能做到了
Shure: We can do it
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 对有点像
Lucia: Yeah, kind of
Jake:我先放那先放这
Jake: I'll put this here first
Jake:多少有点丑
Jake: It's a bit ugly
Jake:哇好有那种高级料理的感觉
Jake: Wow, it looks so fancy
Tasha: 哇好有这种高级料理的哈哈
Tasha: Wow, it really looks so fancy, haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 不会夸就硬夸
Tasha: When you can't praise, just force it
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:这个倒还行哎
Jake: This one is actually alright
Tasha: 这个还行
Tasha: This one's okay.
Tasha: 你要放在一起吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it together?
Tasha: 就给一个人吃
Tasha: Just let one person eat it.
Jake:好再来一个
Jake: Okay, let's do another one.
Lucia: 咱这盘还够吗
Lucia: Do we have enough on this plate?
Jake:哎杨老板灯关一下
Jake: Hey, Jake, turn off the light.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Lucia: 好这份提拉米苏你去做吧哈哈
Lucia: Okay, you go make this tiramisu. Haha.
Jake:哪哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 没事这个做的很好
Lucia: It's fine, this one is really good.
Jake:好这个还行
Jake: Okay, this one's okay.
Lucia: 嗯好看
Lucia: Yeah, it looks nice.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Tasha: 就是那种这么大一个坎
Tasha: It's like there's this big hurdle.
Tasha: 然后里面就一个小姐
Tasha: And then there's just one girl inside.
Lucia: 哈哈哎
Lucia: Haha, hey!
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 对对对确实很高级
Lucia: Yeah, it's really fancy.
Lucia: 我咋觉得咱这盘子
Lucia: Why do I feel like this plate...
Lucia: 要不我上楼看看
Lucia: I'll go check upstairs.
Jake:唯一的拿得出手的东西
Jake: The only thing that's presentable.
Tasha: 无一例外
Tasha: Without exception.
Katrina: 耶耶
Katrina: Yay, yay!
Lucia: 啊我又拿了几个盘子
Lucia: Ah, I brought a few more plates.
Lucia: 稍等冲一下哈
Lucia: Hold on, let me rinse them.
Lucia: 哎呀咦咦咦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my, oh my, oh my god.
Jake:切蛋糕一般怎么切啊谢谢您
Jake: How do you usually cut a cake? Thank you.
Tasha: 哇这一般就是高级料理的样子
Tasha: Wow, this is what high-end cuisine looks like.
Jake:哎呀这东西不能放
Jake: Oh no, this thing can't be left out.
Jake:还有一个串是吧
Jake: There's one more skewer, right?
Jake:把成品做成的原材料感觉
Jake: Making the finished product feel like raw materials.
Jake:哈哈哈把成品做成的原材料
Jake: Haha, making the finished product feel like raw materials.
Lucia: 怎怎么了
Lucia: What happened?
Jake:哈哈哈就是
Jake: Haha, it's just...
Lucia: 哈哈哈您怎么想到的
Lucia: Haha, how did you come up with that?
Jake:就是我觉得我好像一开始那个太阳
Jake: I just feel like at first, that sun...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:就是我一开始打的那个奶油
Jake: It's like the cream I whipped at the start...
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:打出来的挺开心的好
Jake: It was really fun to hit it.
Jake:像也这样
Jake: Just like this.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay.
Lucia: 他短暂的作为成品存在了一会对
Lucia: It briefly existed as a finished product, right.
Jake:啊存在过存在过
Jake: Ah, it did exist, it did.
Jake:妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Shure: 周一晚上才能回去
Shure: I can only go back on Monday night.
Jake:这个这个挺好
Jake: This, this is pretty good.
Lucia: 而且它作为成品的时候吧
Lucia: And when it was a finished product,
Lucia: 它是一种传统艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: It was a traditional art cake.
Alice:never let you go
Alice: Never let you go.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 现在切完之后呢
Lucia: Now after cutting it,
Lucia: 它成了一种当代艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: It has become a contemporary art cake.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 所以说实际上是一种审美上的进步
Lucia: So actually, it's an aesthetic improvement.
Jake:哈哈我去我去
Jake: Haha, oh my gosh.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 嗯可能就是
Lucia: Hmm, maybe it's just that
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Lucia: 咨询界少了一个乱说PPT的人才
Lucia: The consulting industry lost a talent who talks nonsense in PPT.
Jake:呀
Jake: Oh no.
Lucia: 哎现在盘子够了吗
Lucia: Hey, do we have enough plates now?
Tasha: 够了 这个我吃
Lucia: 哦居然够了
Lucia: Oh, we actually have enough.
Jake:这样够了
Jake: This is enough.
Lucia: 嗯正好是我刚刚洗那盘
Lucia: Hmm, it's just the one I just washed.
Lucia: 要不我就用这个算了
Lucia: Otherwise, I'll just use this one.
Alice:can't buy me
Alice: Can't buy me.
Lucia: 感觉好像是
Lucia: Feels like it is.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:看看我的四号
Jake:确实不太高
Jake: It's really not that tall.
Jake:快长高啊
Jake: Grow taller quickly.
Lucia: 没事时给他多挤点奶油
Lucia: It's okay, just squeeze more cream on it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你弟弟
Jake: Your brother.
Jake:你弟弟怎么长高啊
Jake: How did your brother grow taller?
Jake:怎么长高啊
Jake: How did he grow taller?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 这个是咱们的是吧
Lucia: This one is ours, right?
Lucia: OK我把这就放
Lucia: OK, I'll put it here.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 现在是放下
Lucia: Now put it down.
Lucia: 看看他们外面进度如何了
Lucia: Let's see how their progress outside is going.
Jake:别哭
Jake: Don't cry.
Jake:怎么了没事没事好嘞
Jake: What's wrong? It's okay, it's okay, alright.
Jake:为等饭吃
Jake: Waiting for food.
Jake:哎呦哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, haha.
Alice:是不是如果真的要烤 碳应该多点就整个
Shure: 铺满然后大概而且要要要铺高一点
Shure: Spread it out evenly and make sure it's a bit higher.
Jake:好再打碎
Jake: Okay, break it again.
Shure: 它离离得感觉有点远是吧
Shure: It feels a bit far, right?
Jake:没电了
Jake: It's out of power.
Jake:好餐前甜点
Jake: Alright, pre-dinner dessert.
Jake:餐前甜点吃
Jake: Have some pre-dinner dessert.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:20%吧
Jake: About 20%, right?
Jake:吧这么多啊好
Jake: So much, okay.
Jake:吃吗好吃
Jake: Want to eat? It's good.
Lucia: 特别好
Lucia: It's really good.
Jake:我们都干了什么呀
Jake: What did we do?
Jake:你在里面干了什么
Jake: What did you do in there?
Jake:奶油奶油
Jake: Cream, cream.
Jake:哦就是最后刮的那个
Jake: Oh, it's the final scrape.
Jake:嗯对基本上都是大概有OK
Jake: Mm, yeah, basically, it's all good. Okay.
Jake:我干了什么呀
Jake: What did I do?
Tasha: 您干了多了去
Tasha: You did a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈我一开始打了那个
Jake: Haha, at the beginning, I mixed that.
Jake:打了那是什么呀
Jake: What was that?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:就是让他起
Jake: It's just to make it rise.
Jake:呃怎么说呀
Jake: Uh, how to say...
Jake:就是让他立起来
Jake: To make it stand up.
Jake:那是干嘛的啊
Jake: What is that for?
Tasha: 啊啊蛋糕胚
Tasha: Ah, ah, cake base.
Jake:啊那是干嘛的呀蛋糕胚
Jake: Ah, what's that for? Cake base.
Jake:主要是欠了4层的功劳是吧
Jake: Mainly because we owe four layers of credit, right?
Jake:我也觉得
Jake: I agree.
Lucia: 我自己觉得超好吃
Lucia: I think it's super delicious.
Jake:嗯奶油好吃
Jake: Yeah, the cream is tasty.
Lucia: 谢谢老师夸奖哈哈哈
Lucia: Thanks for the compliment, teacher. Hahaha.
Lucia: 咱俩是不是得给老师点精神损失费啊
Lucia: Should we give the teacher some compensation?
Lucia: 你说哈哈哈哈
Lucia: What do you think? Hahaha.
Jake:老师我给你烤肉去好吧
Jake: Teacher, I'll grill some meat for you, okay?
Jake:老师你要吃什么肉
Jake: Teacher, what kind of meat do you want?
Lucia: 嗯很棒很棒
Lucia: Yeah, very good, very good.
小薇 ：很棒很棒
Tasha: Very good, very good.
Tasha: 接下来就是下一个
Tasha: Next up is the next one.
Lucia: 是不是要再打一些
Lucia: Should we whip some more?
小薇 ：对淡奶油要再打一次
Tasha: Yes, we need to whip the cream again.
Tasha: 嗯反正都打奶油好嘞
Tasha: Yeah, just whip all the cream.
Lucia: 哦那行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 然后还是称
Lucia: And then we weigh it.
Lucia: 直接把盆放电子秤上
Lucia: Just put the bowl on the scale.
Tasha: 你觉这个奶油甜度刚刚好吗
Tasha: Do you think the cream's sweetness is just right?
Lucia: 我觉得可以
Lucia: I think it's fine.
Tasha: 那这样的话就还是按1:10的比例
Tasha: Then let's stick to a 1:10 ratio.
Lucia: 你觉得呢
Lucia: 其实我还蛮爱吃甜食的
Tasha: 我觉得我们奶油快用完了
Lucia: 啊那是那个生蚝 是不是还没烤
Lucia: 嗯准备出去了吗
Lucia: Are you ready to go out?
Jake:我来拿点肉过来
Jake: I'll go get some meat.
Alice:你们可以先吃一点点
Alice: You guys can have a little bit first.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:吃什么
Jake: Eat what?
Alice:在那个盘里
Alice: From that plate.
Alice:我夹过去了
Alice: I already served it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:杨老板你是不是饿了
Alice: Jake, are you hungry?
Jake:呃呃还行还行
Jake: Uh, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:好了我来领
Jake: Alright, I'll fetch it.
Jake:有多的碗吗
Jake: Do we have extra bowls?
Jake:没有好的好的
Jake: No? Okay, okay.
Katrina: 没有直接上筷子吧
Katrina: No, just use chopsticks directly.
Jake:给你们夹肉
Jake: I'll get some meat for you.
Jake:嗯整个盘子吧
Jake: Hmm, maybe the whole plate.
Lucia: 刚不是有个盘子好像
Lucia: Didn't we have a plate just now?
Jake:这这3个盘子是
Jake: These three plates are...
Lucia: 呃那个盘
Lucia: Uh, that plate.
Lucia: 那那几盘还要冲一下
Lucia: Those plates need to be rinsed.
Lucia: 就是我刚拿下来本来要放蛋糕的
Lucia: The ones I just took down for the cake.
Jake:好冲一冲
Jake: Okay, rinse them.
Lucia: 但后来够了然后就没没再管他
Lucia: But we had enough, so I didn't bother.
Jake:好那个串
Jake: Alright, those skewers.
Lucia: 这里还有个串
Lucia: There's another skewer here.
Jake:这叫啥名字来着
Jake: What's this called again?
Jake:就叫这个
Jake:嗯好的对
Jake: Hmm, okay, right.
Tasha: 叫纸杯戚风
Tasha: It's called chiffon cupcake.
Tasha: 爆浆巧克力蛋糕
Tasha: Molten chocolate cake.
Jake:戚风是什么意思
Jake: What does chiffon mean?
Jake:戚风是指很蓬松的意思
Jake: Chiffon means it's very fluffy.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈好的
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:给他独特的风味
Jake: It gives it a unique flavor.
Jake:来拿脸走
Jake: Come on, take the face away.
Shure: 这都都都拿走吧大厨
Shure: Take everything away, chef.
Jake:拿脸进去
Jake: Take the face inside.
Jake:怎么能都拿走啊
Jake: How can you take everything away?
Jake:不能都拿走
Jake: You can't take everything.
Shure: 基本人都在里面吧
Shure: Most people are inside, right?
Katrina: 天呐我灯还亮着吗你帮
Katrina: Oh my, are my lights still on? Can you help?
Jake:亮着很亮
Jake: They're on, very bright.
Jake:哦你们都来了
Jake: Oh, you all came.
Jake:好那吃吧
Jake: Alright, let's eat.
Shure: 我又给AI数据集贡献了一些
Shure: I contributed some more data to the AI dataset.
Shure: 人类在远程沟通了一些方式
Shure: Humans have found some ways to communicate remotely.
Jake:喝什么
Jake: What to drink?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I.
Jake:好喝
Jake: Tastes good.
Jake:还缺筷子吗
Jake: Need more chopsticks?
Jake:外面可能是
Jake: Maybe outside.
Lucia: 外面应该不缺
Lucia: Shouldn't be outside.
Jake:应该不存
Jake: Shouldn't be stored.
Lucia: 因为我在外面放了6双
Lucia: I put 6 pairs outside.
Jake:我在外面放了路上
Jake: I put them on the way.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 可以先看一眼
Lucia: Can I take a look first?
Jake:砍一下
Jake: Chop it a bit
Jake:海
Jake: Hi
Jake:他给我标过数据吗
Jake: Did he mark the data for me?
Jake:他没给你标好的
Jake: He didn't mark it for you
Shure: 他没给你标过数据
Shure: He didn't mark the data for you
Jake:唉有吗柠檬
Jake: Hey, do we have lemon?
Lucia: 放了一点应该
Lucia: I think we put a little bit
Jake:噢对一开始给了一点
Jake: Oh right, we put a bit at the beginning
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 等会让我再吃两口再回去打
Lucia: Wait, let me take a few more bites before going back
Shure: 智力低下的那种
Shure: The kind with low intelligence
Lucia: 还像刚打到刚才那种程度好了
Lucia: Just like the level we hit earlier
Jake:这些筷子我就洗一下用生的
Jake: I'll just wash these chopsticks and use them raw
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which ones?
Jake:这些都是生的是吧
Jake: These are all raw, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:哦那我还是拿几个出来
Jake: Oh, then I'll still take a few out
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Katrina: 这这是手
Katrina: This, this is fine
Katrina: 这可以用
Katrina: This can be used
Jake:这个是新的
Jake: This one's new
Katrina: 这干净
Katrina: This is clean
Jake:那你们领
Jake: You guys take it
Jake:你们拿一个
Jake: You guys take one
Jake:我还是吸两个
Jake: I'll still take two
Jake:吸两双出来
Jake: Take two pairs out
Jake:你们领一双吧
Jake: You guys take one pair
Jake:我再拧三双吧
Jake: I'll take three more pairs
Jake:那他克星也有
Jake: Then the countermeasure also has it
Lucia: 咱筷子还够吗
Lucia: Do we still have enough chopsticks?
Jake:够够够够
Jake: Enough, enough, enough
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then
Lucia: 我要不把这双直接洗了算了
Lucia: How about I just wash this pair?
Tasha: 嗯那也行那我现在
Tasha: Yeah, that works, I'll now...
Jake:一起我一起写
Jake: Together, I'll write together
Jake:你来打哎
Jake: You come and play, hey
Tasha: 那我也回去打奶油了
Tasha: Then I'll go back to whip the cream
Jake:对对对你
Jake: Yes, yes, you
Jake:你给师傅服务去
Jake: Go serve the master.
Tasha: 给谁服务师傅
Tasha: Serve who, master?
Jake:师傅
Jake: The master.
Jake:嗯大师
Jake: Yeah, the master.
Jake:那我可不能吃
Jake: I can't eat that.
Jake:怎么洗呀
Jake: How do you wash it?
Jake:洗
Jake: Wash.
Jake:刚拿出来
Jake: Just took it out.
Jake:刚拆封的
Jake: Just unsealed it.
Jake:刚拿出来哦
Jake: Just took it out, oh.
Jake:哎别
Jake: Hey, don't.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 饿过劲了是吧哈哈哈
Shure: You're over your hunger, right? Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Alice:老板这锅快好了
Alice: Boss, the pot's almost ready.
Jake:可以啊哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahaha.
Alice:多了吗杨老板
Alice: Is it too much, Jake?
Jake:期待期待
Jake: Looking forward to it.
Alice:期待期待
Alice: Looking forward to it.
Alice:给你也尝一个
Alice: Here, try one too.
Jake:只是期待
Jake: Just looking forward to it.
Katrina: 你对一个刚刚经历过感情重创的人
Katrina: You know, for someone who just went through a tough breakup,
Katrina: 看你们那种甜蜜的视频
Katrina: watching your sweet videos is really harsh.
Katrina: 真的是杀人诛心啊
Katrina: It's like a stab to the heart.
Jake:可以也可以再考考也可以
Jake: It's okay, you can try again.
Katrina: 真把我气的
Katrina: It's really making me mad.
Lucia: 姚老板来切一下
Lucia: Jake, come and cut this.
Lucia: 裱花袋
Lucia: The piping bag.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 您请哈哈哈
Lucia: Please, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 6个OK
Lucia: Six, okay?
Lucia: 还是像那天那样切一下
Lucia: Cut it like you did the other day.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 刚刚好我们用了
Tasha: We just used six.
Tasha: 刚用了6个
Tasha: Just used six.
Lucia: 现在还用哎
Lucia: Still using it now.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yep, yep.
Lucia: 好剩下8个可以吃了
Lucia: Okay, 8 left to eat.
Lucia: 哈哈不是剩下可以吃了对
Lucia: Haha, no, I mean there are 8 left to eat, right?
Jake:我提着菜刀来了
Jake: I'm here with a cleaver.
Jake:这嗯
Jake: Well...
Jake:有用吗
Jake: Is it useful?
Jake:好有一点用
Jake: Okay, it's a bit useful.
Lucia: 这个盘刚
Lucia: This plate is just...
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯我在好像没充过
Lucia: Hmm, I think I've never charged it.
Jake:没没冲过
Jake: Never charged it?
Lucia: 啥冲一下
Lucia: What, charge it once?
Jake:没冲过就这么装
Jake: If you haven't charged it, just install it like this.
Jake:我可会了
Jake: I got it.
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Jake:那必须的
Jake: Of course.
Tasha: 我连上了吗
Tasha: Am I connected?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake:你没连上
Jake: You're not connected.
Jake:好那就再连一下
Jake: Okay, let's connect again.
Jake:是吗对确实
Jake: Really? Yes, indeed.
Jake:展现两人的合作力对
Jake: Show the teamwork of both, right.
Jake:没电了哎
Jake: Out of battery, hey.
Jake:你你插你插管了吗
Jake: Did you plug in the cable?
Tasha: 插了呀
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Jake:那你你哎确实好了
Jake: Then you... oh, it's done.
Tasha: 好了20240418
Tasha: Done, 20240418.
Jake:好来对一下
Jake: Okay, let's check it.
Jake:对一下时间
Jake: Check the time.
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh wow.
Tasha: 好开始了
Tasha: Alright, starting.
Jake:来看一眼
Jake: Let's take a look.
Tasha: 看了
Tasha: I've seen it.
Jake:看了好
Jake: Seen it? Good.
Jake:VR我们也一起看一下
Jake: Let's look at the VR together.
Jake:好的好看我
Jake: Okay, look at me.
Lucia: 但我看到的是反的啊
Lucia: But I'm seeing it reversed.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 好了吗好
Tasha: Is it done? Okay.
Jake:好可以
Jake: Okay, it's fine.
Tasha: 继续
Tasha: Continue.
Jake:呃在这
Jake: Uh, over here.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:有点烘焙天赋在身上吧
Jake: You've got a bit of a baking talent, don't you?
Tasha: 有点烘焙天赋在身上的哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, a bit of baking talent, hahaha.
Jake:啊这么回事
Jake: Ah, that's how it is.
Jake:多少 0.5%技能点点吧
Jake: How much? About 0.5% skill points?
Tasha: 技能点点满
Tasha: Maxed out skill points.
Jake:0.3%不能再多了
Jake: 0.3%, no more than that.
Jake:好好好可以
Jake: Alright, alright, that's good.
Tasha: 切 切了吗
Tasha: 哦对吧
Tasha: Oh, right?
Jake:好我来切
Lucia: 刀还用这个刀吗
Lucia: Are we still using this knife?
Tasha: 你不切了吗
Tasha: Aren't you cutting anymore?
Jake:啊我要切
Tasha: 啊你好忙呀哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, you're so busy, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈好好好你来切
Lucia: 啊那我来挤哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, then I'll squeeze, hahaha.
Tasha: 那我来切
Tasha: Then I'll cut.
Lucia: 短暂的换一下任务
Lucia: Let's switch tasks for a bit.
Jake:那我给你们加油
Jake: Then I'll cheer you on.
Lucia: 这个这个放在这
Lucia: Put this here.
Lucia: 这案板应该可以直接用
Lucia: This cutting board should work.
Tasha: 你们一人切一半吧
Tasha: You two cut half each.
Lucia: 一人可啊
Lucia: Yeah, each can do half.
Tasha: 啊你们一人挤一半吧
Tasha: Ah, you two squeeze half each.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Jake:帮我救救4吧
Jake: Help me save 4.
Jake:经济学大师
Jake: Economics expert.
Tasha: 救4是什么意思哦
Tasha: What does saving 4 mean?
Lucia: 就是吗你说的是哦 4 嗯嗯
Lucia: You mean saving 4, right?
Lucia: 经济学还是有些解决不了的问题
Lucia: Economics still has some unsolvable problems.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 你知道吗哈哈
Lucia: You know? Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:4号真的好惨
Jake: Number 4 is really miserable.
Lucia: 给他多放点奶油吧
Lucia: Give him more cream.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 咱给他放一个大的草莓或者
Lucia: Let's put a big strawberry or something.
Tasha: 我这个人还是很公平的
Tasha: I'm a very fair person.
Tasha: 没有大葱哎
Tasha: No green onions, though.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:市场不允许
Jake: The market doesn't allow it.
Jake:像这么回事啊
Jake: That's how it is.
Lucia: 特别香就是这么回事
Lucia: It's especially fragrant, that's how it is.
Jake:来请
Jake: Please, go ahead.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow, wow.
Jake:哇你这贴的好好看
Jake: Wow, you pasted it so nicely.
Lucia: 哇好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks good.
Lucia: 这个草莓看着就让人觉得食欲大开
Lucia: This strawberry looks so appetizing.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 大家都很会夸
Tasha: Everyone's really good at complimenting.
Lucia: 这应该挤多点挤少点就像那天那样挤
Lucia: Should we squeeze more or less, like we did that day?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 你那个艺术蛋糕很艺术
Tasha: Your artistic cake is very artistic.
Tasha: 那天起的哈哈
Tasha: That day was hilarious.
Jake:哈哈哈这个我觉得像在化鸟巢
Jake: Haha, I think it's like drawing a bird's nest.
Lucia: 哈哈你看我每次都把它踢不断好怪哦
Lucia: Haha, look, I always can't break it off, it's so weird.
Jake:这回弄水立方
Jake: This time, make it a water cube.
Lucia: 哎你就弄方一点是吧
Lucia: Oh, you mean make it more square, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 谁说不行呢
Lucia: Who says we can't?
Lucia: 但是他中间就会逐渐那个啥
Lucia: But in the middle, it will gradually do that thing.
Jake:哦你还得给他封个顶
Jake: Oh, you still have to seal the top.
Tasha: 空
Tasha: Empty.
Lucia: 对没事我会有草莓的
Lucia: Yeah, no worries, I'll have strawberries.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 这就叫凯恩斯经济学
Lucia: This is called Keynesian economics.
Lucia: 就我们只看短期
Lucia: We only look at the short term.
Lucia: 长远的这些另说
Lucia: We'll talk about the long term later.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我们这个恩格尔系数拉满了
Tasha: Our Engel coefficient is maxed out.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 就是啊我们的预算都用在支撑
Lucia: Yeah, our budget is all about support.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 有点丑就这样吧
Lucia: It's a bit ugly, let's leave it at that.
Jake:不丑不丑
Jake: Not ugly, not ugly.
Lucia: 不过我觉得我们剩这个还挺多的是
Lucia: But I think we have quite a lot left.
Lucia: 我前几个挤太少了
Lucia: I squeezed too little earlier.
Lucia: 点缀哎可以先我把这一圈给画完
Lucia: For decoration, let me finish drawing this circle first.
Lucia: 画都画了
Lucia: I've already drawn it.
Lucia: 给他封口吧
Lucia: Let's seal it.
Lucia: 哎呀断了
Lucia: Oh no, it broke.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 那就将错就错了
Lucia: Let's just go with it then.
Lucia: 大家都是很豁达的人
Lucia: Everyone here is very easygoing.
Jake:哎发生什么了
Jake: Hey, what happened?
Lucia: 哇内外都在欢声笑语哈哈
Lucia: Wow, there's laughter and joy inside and out, haha.
Jake:哈哈来打听打听
Jake: Haha, let's find out.
Tasha: 外面进度怎么样了能吃吗
Tasha: How's the progress outside, can we eat?
Jake:发生什么事了
Jake: What happened?
Tasha: 里面的进度已经快结束了
Tasha: The progress inside is almost done.
Alice:拿盘子吧
Alice: Grab the plates.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 啊都可以
Tasha: Ah, it's all good.
Tasha: 你挤吧你们一人挤6个
Tasha: You squeeze, each of you do 6.
Jake:你们一人举六个
Jake: Each of you do 6.
Tasha: 好谢谢老师啊
Tasha: Okay, thank you, teacher.
Jake:好我来去
Jake: Alright, I'll go.
Jake:我领肉去
Jake: I'll go get the meat.
Jake:这盘子OK
Jake: This plate is OK.
Tasha: 我们不一起出去吃吗
Tasha: Aren't we eating together?
Tasha: 挤完就出去吧
Tasha: Let's go after squeezing.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 没事让他先领吧
Lucia: It's fine, let him go first.
Lucia: 挤可能还要挤
Lucia: We might need to squeeze more.
Lucia: 挤完还得一小会
Lucia: It'll take a little while longer.
Lucia: 然后咱就可以把这都端出去了
Lucia: Then we can take all this out.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh dear.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha: 哦这个记得不错谢谢
Tasha: Oh, you remembered well, thanks.
Jake:我先把盘子送出去
Jake: I'll take the plates out first.
Jake:我来送盘子来了
Jake: I'm here to deliver the plates.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好了你的6个已领完
Tasha: Alright, your 6 are done.
Tasha: 今日任务领取完毕
Tasha: Today's task is complete.
Tasha: 哈哈哈换下一位小朋友吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha, let's move on to the next kid, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Lucia: 今日任务
Lucia: Today's task...
Lucia: 今日任务已完成
Lucia: Today's task is complete.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my!
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 下一个小朋友
Tasha: Next kid.
Tasha: 你多几点
Tasha: What time is it for you?
Jake:我想想我怎么把它给填满
Jake: Let me think about how to fill it up.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Alright, thanks.
Lucia: 留给下一位小朋友的
Lucia: Leave it for the next kid.
Lucia: 这个这个余额还有很多哈哈
Lucia: There's still a lot of balance left, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:那我一开始得使劲的挥霍一番
Jake: Then I should splurge right from the start.
Lucia: 哈哈你真是批人哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, you're really something, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈不知道他急什么救命啊
Tasha: Haha, I don't know why he's in such a hurry, help!
Lucia: 你在蛋糕上做雕塑吗
Lucia: Are you sculpting on the cake?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 女人你在玩火哈
Tasha: Woman, you're playing with fire, haha.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Lucia: 可以可以特别好
Lucia: It's great, really good.
Tasha: 特别好
Tasha: Really good.
Lucia: 就是有种不知所云的美感
Lucia: It has a kind of inexplicable beauty.
Tasha: 那个那个那个杜上的那个小便池
Tasha: Like that, that urinal by Duchamp.
Lucia: 有那个杜尚的那个
Lucia: It has that Duchamp vibe.
Lucia: 哈哈小编池哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, urinal, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈OK
Jake: Hahaha, OK.
Tasha: 对你知道吗
Tasha: Yeah, you know?
Tasha: 就是图上图上他是一个艺术家
Tasha: It's like, he's an artist.
Jake:OK我知道了
Jake: OK, got it.
Tasha: 他把小便池作为一件艺术品
Tasha: He made a urinal into an art piece.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 对然后名字叫全
Lucia: Yeah, and it's called "Fountain."
Lucia: 哈哈我见过这个艺术品的实物
Lucia: Haha, I've seen the actual piece.
Jake:哈哈哈我见过这个艺术品的实物
Jake: Haha, I've seen the actual piece.
Lucia: 我在伦敦的泰特美术馆里
Lucia: At the Tate Museum in London.
Lucia: 然后有一个小哥从旁边走过去
Lucia: Then a guy walked by.
Lucia: 一个外国人
Lucia: A foreigner.
Jake:就去了
Jake: And he went over there.
Lucia: 对然后他当时看了一眼这个
Lucia: Yeah, then he glanced at this.
Lucia: 然后跟他旁身边一个女生
Lucia: And with a girl next to him,
Lucia: 可能是他女票或者之类的
Lucia: maybe his girlfriend or something,
Lucia: 说这是个坚持吧
Lucia: said, "This is a persistence, right?"
Tasha: 哈哈对但他觉得他是一个艺术品
Tasha: Haha, yeah, but he thought it was an artwork.
Jake:哈哈对
Jake: Haha, right.
Jake:对要不来一个
Jake: Yeah, why not try one?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ahaha.
Lucia: 别别别别
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 咱这是吃的
Lucia: We're eating this.
Jake:来一个艺术品
Jake: Let's make it an artwork.
Tasha: 是吗好的那我给他来个小点的水果
Tasha: Really? Okay, I'll make a small fruit.
Jake:那得竖竖上去
Jake: It needs to stand up.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this?
Tasha: 你想另外还是另外
Tasha: Do you mean this way or the other?
Jake:对他
Jake: Yeah, like that.
Lucia: 这垫在后边他不用倒
Lucia: This goes in the back, so it won't fall.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Tasha: 我知道了您肯定是想表达这样的想法
Tasha: I got it. You definitely mean this idea.
Jake:猜你想搜
Jake: Guess what you're searching for.
Lucia: 猜你想搜哈哈哈
Lucia: Guess what you're searching for, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈再来两个
Jake: Hahaha, let's do two more.
Lucia: 哎好看哎
Lucia: Wow, it looks good.
Jake:要不不够了是吧
Jake: Otherwise, it's not enough, right?
Tasha: 啊没关系还可以再切哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, no worries, we can cut more, haha.
Lucia: 没关系我来洗
Lucia: It's okay, I'll wash it.
Jake:哦哦哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, oh, haha.
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my!
Tasha: 哇直接变好看了哈哈
Tasha: Wow, it turned out beautiful, haha.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Tasha: 真挺好
Tasha: Really nice.
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: It’s great.
Tasha: 奇怪的造型
Tasha: A weird shape.
Jake:还能再做什么哈哈哈
Jake: What e
Lucia: 没事不管是啥造型
Lucia: It's okay, no matter what style it is.
Lucia: 咱都能给他整成跟那一样的
Lucia: We can make it look just like that.
Jake:哎好的好那我再来一个
Jake: Alright, good, then I'll do another one.
Tasha: 对对都会整好看的
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, we'll make it look nice.
Tasha: 您放心吧
Tasha: Don't worry.
Tasha: 好别做一样的
Tasha: Alright, don't make it the same.
Tasha: 发挥您的创造力
Tasha: Use your creativity.
Jake:哦好吧OK
Jake: Oh, okay, sure.
Shure: 宣告下线了今天把线还给你了
Jake:哎好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 不要再污蔑我了
Jake:哈哈哈没污蔑
Tasha: 要干嘛好
Tasha: What should we do next?
Tasha: 你还要再加一下是吗
Tasha: You want to add more, right?
Jake:再加一个
Jake: Add one more.
Tasha: 好加一个
Tasha: Sure, add one more.
Jake:不不不加加右边
Jake: No, no, no, add to the right side.
Tasha: 就就这种不对称美感是吗
Tasha: So, this kind of asymmetrical beauty, right?
Jake:对对对好的好的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Tasha: 啊好的好的
Tasha: Ah, got it.
Tasha: 太会了
Tasha: You are so good at this.
Lucia: 给大家来一些草莓补给
Lucia: Let's bring some strawberries for everyone.
Tasha: 我感觉就是很鲜明的能看出
Tasha: I feel like you can clearly see
Tasha: 这是两个人的风格
Tasha: the style of two different people.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:我刚刚架了一堵墙
Jake: I just built a wall.
Lucia: 啊可以
Lucia: Ah, nice.
Lucia: 挺挺酷炫
Lucia: Pretty cool.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake:然后干点啥呢
Jake: So, what should we do next?
Shure: 嗨 siri你在哪 siri
Shure: 我靠不是你们
Shure: Oh my god, are you guys
Shure: 你们怎么这个样子对我的PAD
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 同志们烧烤组说外面现在火挺好的
Lucia: Guys, the BBQ team says the fire outside is good now.
Lucia: 大家可以出来了好的
Lucia: Everyone can come out now, alright.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:炮台啊这是
Jake: Is this a fort?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah, yeah.
Lucia: 为什么这个草莓变得越来越多
Lucia: Why are there more and more strawberries?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈完了这个要弄4个哈
Jake: Hahahahaha, we need to make four of these.
Lucia: 咱草莓不够啊
Lucia: We don't have enough strawberries.
Tasha: 已经没有了吧
Tasha: They're all gone, right?
Lucia: 还有几个
Lucia: There's still a few.
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:这个可以弄一个
Jake: We can make one with this.
Tasha: 好大呀换个小的
Tasha: It's too big, let's switch to a smaller one.
Jake:可以可以你是怎么弄完你说
Jake: Sure, sure, how did you finish it?
Jake:哈哈 哦OK OK
Jake: Haha, oh OK, OK.
Tasha: 没关系再把前面几个点缀点缀
Tasha: It's fine, just decorate the front a bit more.
Tasha: 后面每个都各有风格
Tasha: Each one has its own style.
Jake:对这个怎么办呢
Jake: Yeah, what should we do with this one?
Jake:您随意吧好的
Jake: Do whatever you like, it's fine.
Tasha: 你已经随意过头了哈
Tasha: You've gone a bit too far.
Jake:弄个帘洞哈哈哈
Jake: Make a curtain hole, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 哈梦幻联动
Tasha: Haha, a dreamy crossover.
Lucia: 双厨狂喜
Lucia: Double chef delight.
Alice:这个是滋滋冒油版
Alice: This is the sizzling version.
Lucia: 不是这是可以录的吗
Lucia: Is it okay to record this?
Jake:对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 要不要记录一下时间
Lucia: Should we note the time?
Jake:哈哈哈确实不能说
Jake: Haha, we really shouldn't mention it.
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It's that...
Jake:呃马来西亚吉隆坡
Jake: Uh, the Petronas Towers in Kuala Lumpur.
Jake:合合理了吧
Jake: Makes sense, right?
Lucia: 嗯特别合理
Lucia: Yeah, totally makes sense.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:就是双子塔
Jake: Just twin towers.
Jake:有很多吧
Jake: There are many, right?
Jake:咱也不说那一个
Jake: We're not talking about that one.
Lucia: 那你加这一句
Lucia: Then you add this line.
Jake:就合理了
Jake: Makes sense now.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks great.
Tasha: 逐渐变稀
Tasha: It's getting thinner.
Lucia: 是因为受热了吗对
Lucia: Is it because of the heat?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no!
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 翻出去吧
Tasha: Flip it over.
Tasha: 特别棒主厨
Tasha: Amazing, Chef.
Jake:开饭了
Jake: Dinner's ready!
Jake:来这是餐前甜点还是餐后甜点
Jake: Is this an appetizer or dessert?
Alice:鸡翅好了
Alice: The wings are ready.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:每人拿一个吧
Alice: Everyone take one.
Jake:哈餐中甜点
Jake: Haha, mid-meal dessert.
Tasha: 啦啦
Tasha: La la.
Jake:哦这个怎么倒的呀
Jake: Oh, how do you pour this?
Jake:小灯
Jake: Little light.
Jake:来啊就倒着是吧
Jake: Come on, just like this, right?
Alice:啊就是让那样亮一点的
Alice: Ah, just make it a bit brighter.
Jake:啊就更近一点是吧
Jake: Oh, just closer, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哪了这个
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:我洗的筷子在这
Jake: My washed chopsticks are here.
Jake:呃应该没用了
Jake: Uh, probably not usable now.
Tasha: 我没有问
Tasha: I didn't ask.
Jake:嗯那还有一个我也为谁了
Jake: Hmm, then there's one more, who is it for?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha: 过
Tasha: Pass.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯啊谢谢
Lucia: Mm-hmm, thank you.
Lucia: 我说这双看起来并不像没用过的样子
Lucia: I said this pair doesn't look unused.
Lucia: 我冲一下来着
Lucia: I rinsed them.
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哎好烫啊我靠
Jake: Oh, it's hot!
Lucia: 呃不是您在干嘛
Lucia: Uh, what are you doing?
Jake:好烫啊
Jake: So hot!
Jake:好烫啊我靠
Lucia: 啊终于吃掉了
Lucia: Ah, finally ate it.
Shure: 并不简单如呼吸
Shure: It's not as easy as breathing.
Shure: 我真的希望你能力气
Shure: I really hope you can muster up some courage.
Shure: 若没交心
Shure: If we don't open up to each other,
Shure: 怎么说明
Shure: how can I explain
Shure: 我真的爱你
Shure: that I truly love you?
Shure: 算了算了不丢人了
Shure: Forget it, forget it, let's not embarrass ourselves.
Alice:盘子我觉得趁热吃好吃
Alice: I think it's better to eat the dish while it's hot.
Alice:来盘吧
Alice: Let's dig in.
Jake:今天的架子鼓打打怎么样
Jake: How about we play the drums today?
Shure: 你别说后面还可以的
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:哦挺好
Jake: Oh, sounds good.
Tasha: 听过盘尼西林吗
Tasha: Have you heard of Penicillin?
Jake:听过真的吗
Jake: Have I heard of it? Really?
Jake:真的听过
Jake: I really have.
Jake:盘尼西林是真听过
Jake:对是对
Jake: Yeah, for sure.
Shure: 那你一定知道他们的环境吧
Jake:呃可能知道
Jake: Uh, maybe I know it.
Jake:应该知道吧
Jake: I should know it, right?
Jake:我来烤会
Jake: Let me grill for a bit.
Jake:我帮你一会
Jake: I'll help you out.
Jake:那得用啊
Jake: You need to use it, right?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:这个碳是弄碎了吗
Jake: Did you crush this charcoal?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 你为什么不鼓掌
Shure: 好 唱完了你就带上了是吧
Jake:来吃一个
Jake: Come on, have a bite.
Jake:吃个什么呢我去
Jake: What should I eat, I wonder.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tastes good.
Tasha: 吃到爆浆了吗还没有
Tasha: Did you get to the juicy part yet? Not yet?
Jake:还没还没打开
Jake: Not yet, haven't opened it.
Jake:爆浆什么时候爆的
Jake: When does it get juicy?
Jake:我咋不知道
Jake: How come I don't know?
Tasha: 成为主厨哈哈
Tasha: Becoming the chef, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 怎么能什么都知道呢哈哈
Lucia: How can you know everything, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你不没带耳机吗
Shure: Didn't you not bring your headphones?
Shure: 你知道我为什么摘下来吗
Shure: Do you know why I took them off?
Shure: 你好烦啊
Shure: You're so annoying.
Shure: 能不能留点面子
Shure: Can you give me a break?
Shure: 留点面子
Shure: Give me some face.
Jake:挺好看的
Jake: It looks pretty good.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 你不喝的话
Tasha: If you don't drink it
Tasha: 我我认为你这杯酒可以吗好的
Tasha: I think this glass of wine, is it okay for you? Alright.